50% des échouages de bretagne et bien
c'est ici et cette année ces échouages
sont arrivés encore plus tôt que
d'habitude et la décomposition des
algues vertes
ces vins gage nauséabond qui détruisent
la faune la flore ya plus de vers de
vase
il ya plus de bigorneaux et y'a pus
maintenant d'estivants dupuis la commune
du lion le militant écologiste
andré ollivro est ulcéré de voir le
littoral breton ainsi empoisonné par les
algues vertes
ce fléau apparu il ya une cinquantaine
d'années envahi les côtes par dizaines
de milliers de tonnes du calvados à la
charente-maritime 90% de cette pollution
est concentrée en bretagne la cause des
exploitations agricoles intensives en
particulier l'élevage du porc dont les
déjections pénètre le sol des nappes
phréatiques les cours d'eau et
produisent des nitrates
ils sont rejetés à la mer et agissent
comme un engrais pour les algues vertes
qui se mettent à proliférer surtout
durant les années chaudes et peu
venteuse les militants décident de
tester une source d'eau à proximité
c'est un appareil qui permet de mesurer
le taux de nitrates 55 mg de nitrates
par litre d'eau au dessus de 10 mg de
nitrates
vous avez des marées vertes dans l'eau
et pourquoi cette eau est polluée
et bien tout simplement au dessus il ya
des champs de maïs et ge ont épandu du
lisier il ya quelques temps les algues
vertes en état de décomposition et met
un gaz très toxique
l'hydrogène sulfuré sur la plage de la
granville les militants effectué des
relevés
[Musique]
205 ppm c'est dangereux
je peux avoir des problèmes aux poumons
et assez cuite 205 faut savoir qu au
delà de 25 il faut s'en aller et c'est
les ramasseur d'algues vertes ils
doivent de gaz est il au plus vite quoi
il faut en finir avec cette agriculture
intensive
il faut que le paysan redevienne maître
de sa terre et là on retrouvera une
maîtrise de notre territoire et on
évitera de faire en sorte que la
bretagne est ce cancer qu'on appelle le
cancer des algues vertes
au total depuis l'apparition de ce fléau
trois personnes et 39 animaux sont
décédés après un contact prolongé avec
des algues vertes
à tel point que les plages sont parfois
fermé pour des raisons sanitaires
le maire de la commune dit lyon depuis
2014 ou premières loges dénonce le
manque de soutien de l'état nouri viande
et minutes de 40% le taux de nitrates
cependant en fait ce taux de nitrates
est encore trop important pour qu'on
puisse régler le problème des algues
vertes
ils nous font encore redoubler d'efforts
mais redoubler d'efforts d'un point de
vue technique auprès d'eux pour
accompagner la filière écoles pour qu'
on puisse parler de transformation il
faut qu'on accorde des moyens financer
l'effort qui est à mener en amont doit
nécessairement être accompagnée de
manière plus efficace et plus importante
de la part de l'état si en plus on
regarde la structure de notre belle qui
en majeure partie composée de vase et de
zones rocheuses
c'est de se dire que les techniques de
ramassage tels que le tracteur ne
peuvent pas aller sur des sites comme
cela donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait malgré
les 100 millions d'euros consacrés entre
2010 et 2021
les échouages se poursuivre un rapport
de la cour des comptes qui a fuité a
épinglé la faiblesse des moyens et le
manque d'ambition des deux plans de
lutte successifs de la france engagée
depuis 2010 le 4 juin le tribunal
administratif de rennes assommé le
préfet de la bretagne de prendre de
nouvelles mesures pour protéger l'eau et
à quatre mois pour trouver des
stratégies qui pourraient enfin changer
la donne